react native write javascript and react
to build apps for ios android and the
web from a single codebase according to
atwood's law any application that can be
written in javascript will eventually be
written in javascript the first way js
developers tried to build mobile apps
was by wrapping their native
applications in a sandbox browser called
a webview using tools like apache
cordova and adobe phonegap the
philosophy is right once run anywhere
this works but it can be hard to make a
website feel like a true native
experience react native takes a
different approach it feels just like
react dom for the web but instead of
using html and the dom as building
blocks for the ui it uses the native
components that you would find on ios
and android the philosophy is learn once
right anywhere you can't just take your
existing react web app and upload it to
the app store but you can use the react
skills you already have to build a
native app without ever having to touch
java or objective c instead you import
building block components like button
switch scroll view and the most
fundamental of which is view at runtime
it will use the true native component on
the corresponding platform like uiview
android.view or div on the web it's like
building three apps for the price of one
but in some cases you may want a
different visual experience based on the
underlying os the platform module allows
you to check which platform you're on
and render different components
accordingly when it comes to visuals
there's no css in react native instead
every core component takes a style prop
that can be customized with a style
sheet constructed from javascript in
development it supports fast refresh
which means you can instantly see the
changes you make to your code on any
platform you may also want to tap into
native features like the device camera
push notifications and geolocation these
concerns are handled by one of the most
active open source communities on github
there's open source packages for almost
everything that can be installed with
npm just like any other javascript
project and there's frameworks like expo
that build on top of react native
primitives to provide all the tooling
required to ship your app to production
you can use react native to build a
complete mobile app or integrate it with
existing ios and android projects it's
not an all or nothing solution this has
been react native in 100 seconds if you
want to see more short videos like this
hit the like button and subscribe and
let me know if you want to see more
react native content in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one